[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Bradley Horowitz.
I'm one of the VPs of
Product here at Google.
And it's my pleasure to
welcome you to this Authors
at Google talk with
Jerzy Gregorek.
And Jerzy is an
amazing individual.
And I'm learning that the
more I get to know him
and his family, who is
also here, over time.
The reason, nominally,
that we're here
is because he is a world
expert in weightlifting.
He's a champion in weightlifting
and world record holder.
But more generally, in the
categories of fitness, health,
nutrition, aging,
wellness, he's also
made some incredible
contributions that
are documented in his
book, "The Happy Body."
Beyond that, what
I'm learning is
that the story that
brought him on this journey
is equally engaging
and entertaining,
and this takes us into
realms of mindfulness,
philosophy, stoicism, and
that will be woven through.
So it's not just about
diet and exercise,
although those things
are core to his message.
It's also about his
own journey and how
he came upon this knowledge
through direct experience.
So first I'd like to all
take a moment and thank him,
welcome Jerzy here.
OK.
To kick things
off, you're Polish,
but you left that country when
it was communist, 31 years ago.
Why did you leave?
And I heard at the
time, you were already
training for the Olympics
and were also a firefighter?
JERZY GREGOREK: Before I answer,
thank you for inviting me.
And I am so happy that my
wife and my daughter is here.
I've been married for 39 years,
and that's a big achievement.
And we have a lovely daughter
that is 13 years old.
And we are so happy.
And so I was 13 when
I began weightlifting.
And why I did it,
well, in Poland,
people were big and
tall and strong.
So I was short and weak.
So I wanted to find edge for
myself and work on myself,
so those who are very
strong would not really
push me around.
So I started weightlifting
and really fell in love
with the thing.
It was just really fun.
And thus I became
stronger and stronger.
It didn't matter anymore
that the bullies were there.
They just disappeared.
But I continued lifting and
more lifting and falling more
in love with it.
And then when I was 19,
I was an athlete already.
And in Poland, it was
the time that athletes
could go to the fire department
and stay there and compete
for the team.
So I ended up to be a fireman.
And I didn't expect what
would happen to me in the fire
department, but it was quite
an interesting situation.
And the first time when
I went to the fire,
I was in the fire engine.
I was 19 years old.
And I was going there, and I
felt this overwhelming feeling
of goodness.
It was the feeling
of being needed.
And I'd never felt such a
thing, but it was very strong,
and I like it.
It was very
pleasurable and joyful.
So from that moment on, I
loved the fire department.
I liked to be a fireman,
just right there.
So after three years, when
I could leave the fire
department, as if
I was in the Army,
I stayed in the fire department.
And after about five years,
I applied to the Fire Academy
in Warsaw and started
studying there.
And it was '78, and I
studied for four years.
So I studied in the fire.
That's my weight lifting,
actually, time and competing.
And that's the Solidarity time.
In 1981, Solidarity
was the stake
of fighting with the government,
and then the government
did everything so they
could use more powers
to fight demonstrations.
And they tried to take
the fire department
and put the fire department
into the Army, kind
of a paramilitary, so they could
use the whole fire department
against demonstration.
Well, we said, no, we
don't like that idea,
and we went on strike.
And I was one of the
leaders of the strike.
And then the strike, after
negotiations for 10 days,
was brutally put down.
They took us out.
They send terrorist brigade
and tanks and took us out.
After that I found
myself underground.
And after nine years of being a
fireman, suddenly underground.
The government formed a new
academy under a different name
and asked students to sign their
allegiance to the new place.
But it was against, completely,
my ethics and morals,
and I didn't.
So I started being underground.
During this time, when I was in
the academy during the strike,
it was a very difficult
time emotionally,
and people were
under extreme stress.
So they were students,
and there were 400 of us.
And there was a priest who
came to help us, to guide us.
And that priest was
love of the country.
He was like Martin Luther King.
And his sermons were
very inspiring in helping
Polish people to survive
this difficult time.
And the government
hated him so much
at the time, the
communist government,
that they set up capturing him.
And after they captured him
in '84, they would torture him
and martyred him.
So that was '84.
We lost Jerzy.
It was a very difficult
time for Poland in '84.
And I was, at the time--
it was coincidence,
because I was, at the time,
called to the police
department in Szczecin.
And when I was there, I was
lucky because somebody told me
that I should leave,
because where I was I
would never walk out.
So I ran, and then I
went to Sweden in 1985.
So I left Poland.
Poland is a country
that I extremely love,
but it was time to go.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
Poland to Sweden--
was it easy to
get out of Poland,
or did you have to
sort of sneak out?
You say you were
underground, could you
just show up with a passport?
JERZY GREGOREK: It was the
time when the government really
didn't like troublemakers.
You could get the passport.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: They
were happy to see you go.
JERZY GREGOREK:
Out of the country.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
One less problem.
Yeah.
JERZY GREGOREK: Yes.
So when I went to Sweden,
then I went to the Solidarity
again and Stockholm, and then
I faced a different situation.
A lot of people from Solidarity
were divided from the families,
and there were hunger strikes
and all possible scenarios
of pain and suffering.
And then I tried to help
people and talk to people
and then found myself
actually helping them.
So how it happened, I
think, it was because when
I was exposed to Jerzy--
and [? Sjeverni Vorski ?]
was another one--
people had, during
the Solidarity,
something that I've never seen,
and it was unconditional love.
It was just people
who loved people.
It was just amazing.
I'd never seen anything.
I was 27 years old,
and I thought--
I was always suspicious that
people who have unconditional
love, they just
pretend this thing.
And I was exposed to that.
And I was exposed to that
for about three years.
So when I ended up
to be in Sweden,
I started doing some
things, and I could actually
find the right words
for the right person
and the right time.
That I would tell people to
accept the painful situation
and find a solution to
survive and to go on.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So in Sweden, you
were still involved
with the Polish emigres
and connected to what
was going on there.
And at some point, you left
Sweden and came to the US
with basically nothing but
the shirt on your back.
Tell us a little bit about
what happened leaving Sweden.
JERZY GREGOREK: So
when we left Sweden,
we packed everything into
this huge bag-- one bag.
And even our wedding
rings were there
because they told us that
there are metal detectors,
so we have to have everything
in our bag and not on us,
especially metal.
So when we came to New York,
we were sent to Detroit.
We came to New York and
our luggage appeared,
so we put it to Detroit.
And when we arrived in Detroit,
the luggage was not there.
So everything that we
had was in this one bag.
And we had clothes
on and $1,000.
That's all we got.
And I remember, I was very
upset about the whole situation.
And I said, you know what?
Maybe life wants us to be clean.
So we started clean,
and nothing there.
[LAUGHS]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Did they
ever find the luggage?
JERZY GREGOREK: No.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: You should
file a ticket on that.
[LAUGHTER]
JERZY GREGOREK: They gave
a standard-- no. $400.
That's what we got
for this whole thing--
by pound.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
You're literally--
I mean, sometimes people use
it as an expression, nothing
but the shirt on your back,
but you literally had nothing.
What next?
Where do you go?
Where do you turn?
How do you rebuild from nothing?
JERZY GREGOREK: So we
landed in LA, eventually.
We were in Detroit.
We bought the tickets
to LA because we
wanted to be in Santa
Monica, in the place where--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Sunshine.
JERZY GREGOREK: Sunshine and
training, bodybuilding and so
on, fitness.
So before we landed to LA, I
saw all these swimming pools out
there.
And it's huge.
LA is huge.
Right?
So when I saw this
hugeness, I just
thought, wow, all these
people found themselves.
So we'll find
ourselves there, too.
Right?
So it actually quite helped,
because there was just
so-- wow, millions of people.
Wow.
They are good.
We will be good.
And I told Aniela we'd probably
buy a house in two years.
We'll have a pool.
We'd never had a pool, but it
was kind of a dream and joke,
too.
Aniela thought that I was crazy.
I lost myself in
this whole situation.
But two years after,
we built a house.
We have a pool.
Of course, we bought it
when the house was really
the high price, and our first
earthquake came, and then
we had to foreclose the house.
But that's OK, too.
Life happens to you, and not
always good things happen.
Sometimes bad things happen.
But more important is how we
adapt to those things and not
really something else.
But at that time, when we
landed, eventually, in LA,
we found this Polish
couple that helped
us to sleep and to
be in this house
behind that they were building.
And we slept there
for about a month,
and then they helped us to stand
up, and it was really great.
But the first thing that
we did to find a job,
we walked around and try
to find the connections.
We found the President
of American Weightlifting
Association, Bob Hayes, who
told us that weightlifting
coaches don't have any work.
CrossFit was not existing.
So nobody wanted
weight lifting coaches.
It was bad.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Was this about '90?
I mean, a timeline--
JERZY GREGOREK: It was '86.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: '86.
OK.
JERZY GREGOREK: But
he said, there's
something new coming out, which
is called a personal trainer.
So he said, some coaches
like to train regular people.
Some don't like.
They just like
athletes, and that's it.
So I said, well, maybe
we'll find-- so I said,
where do you find these people?
And he said, well, I don't know.
They are somewhere in gyms.
So I said, OK.
So we started walking
from Los Feliz.
And Thursday, we
went to Glendale
and started walking all day.
And in about two weeks,
we walked to Burbank,
and we found a Power Source.
And we told them who we were,
and Aram gave us the first job
as a personal trainer.
What our job was is to write
programs and strategies
and plans for people
that came and wanted
to improve something.
And that could be anything.
It could be flexibility.
It could be energy.
It could be weight loss.
It could be pains and
get rid of medications.
Anything.
Right?
So then I really found
myself, like I really like it.
I like it.
And whatever I wrote,
and whatever I gave
people worked, and
people really like it.
And then I had
probably 100 clients
within three or four months.
It was very fast.
I was busy.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Just
through word of mouth
and people sharing.
JERZY GREGOREK: Yeah.
Three or four months, I
was working 16 hours a day,
Saturday and Sunday.
So we were happy.
We moved into this
little cottage,
and the life has
really been great.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And
so you invented yourself
and invented this practice
of life coaching, training,
helping people.
Nobody handed you a manual.
There was no job description.
You just sort of
went with it, and it
led to a flourishing business.
The threads of that-- has
that really led to Happy Body?
Is this sort of a continuation
from those early days?
JERZY GREGOREK: So it
was the time, in '92,
Aniela thought that we could
start Olympic weightlifting
back.
Because I was injured in Poland.
I was 23.
I was paralyzed, and I had to
stop Olympic weightlifting.
And during the
process of recovery,
I learned a lot
about body and back
and how to heal the body system.
And I did everything to get
myself stronger and stronger
and not challenge the
body to the extremes.
Microprogression was one
of the ways to do it.
But it took years.
And it was '92, and Aniela
said, we are so strong.
Maybe we should go and compete.
We were already past 35.
I will go to it when the
master division starts.
And we started.
I said, OK.
Well, then we have to do
some kind of adjustments.
So I check out my body fat
and my powers and so on.
And it came out that I had to
lose 60 pounds and Aniela 30.
[LAUGHS] And we
did it in one year.
So I projected the numbers
and outlined everything.
And within one year, I
came from 190 to 130.
What I am now.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: You don't
have pictures of this, do you?
I'd love to see the
before and after.
It's hard to imagine you--
JERZY GREGOREK: I
don't have it here.
But I have myself at 180.
[LAUGHS]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Wow.
JERZY GREGOREK: But
it was a strong 190.
It was not really
I had so much fat.
That was bodybuilding training
and powerlifting, bodybuilding
mostly.
So we went into
Olympic weightlifting.
'93 we competed on the
local level, and then
nationals, and then Pan
American Games in '93, '94.
And '95, we entered
the World Championship.
And '97 was the number that
Aniela wanted to really happen.
And that was the World
Championship in Poland.
And the last
competition that I did,
it was '77 at the same city,
actually, 20 years apart.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Had you
been to Poland since or no?
Were you able to visit
in the intervening years?
JERZY GREGOREK: After '89.
Up to '89, a magical place.
A magical thing
happened in '89, right?
Just the whole thing collapsed.
It was just amazing.
It was just beautiful to watch
the Berlin Wall going down.
And I was part of it.
Is was just an amazing fight
with such an overwhelming power
where the communism was.
You could easily lose your
life, or you could easily
be forced to obey
and express that.
It was just a very debilitating
system that actually went down.
And it was, for me,
such a surprise.
Nobody would imagine
in '85, in '86,
that this would happen
in three or four days.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
you had the opportunity
to go back to a
Poland that you loved
and was restored
to the Poland you
wanted it to be and to compete.
So how did that go?
JERZY GREGOREK: Well, that's--
we went to Poland
to compete in '97,
and there were Polish coaches
there and American coaches,
and I represented America there.
And then I won the championship
and Aniela as well.
They called us
the golden couple.
[LAUGHS] But when I
stood in the first place,
and I heard the national
anthem, and it was American,
and I was in Poland, and
there was Polish coaches,
and then Americans
coaches, it was so special.
There is something
with weightlifters
that before the competition
and during competitions
they're really rough
and tough to win.
Everybody wants to win.
But after, you didn't feel
like there is a country, just
friends.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Humanity.
JERZY GREGOREK: Yeah,
it's just beautiful.
I guess it's everywhere
with optimism, maybe.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So this takes us
through your journey, the
triumphant return to Poland,
the World Championship.
And shifting gears a little bit,
let's talk about your program,
The Happy Body.
And I know you have
some slides to show us,
as well as maybe a few videos.
So let's continue
the journey post '97.
JERZY GREGOREK: So
let's go to 2002.
In 2002, we competed
in Melbourne.
There's a Master Olympics,
and we were there.
And there are athletes
between 35 and 100-something.
The first time we see
this scope of athletes.
And there is a
sprinter about 102.
And then at the stadium,
he talks to people.
And he talks like
he's 50 years old.
It's just amazing
when you see people
at that age behaving that way
and having this incredible mind
and health and youthfulness.
It's just amazing.
So I went to see old
weightlifters competing.
And then I saw
Charlie Henderson,
and he was 80 years old.
And he came, and he was going to
lift the weight equals his body
weight.
And I was looking at that,
and I was just thinking, wow,
that's incredible.
80-year-old doing this?
And I'm a poet, so I was
transported into this life when
I was a teenager.
And we were doing this
street lifting, and whoever
was stronger, and so on.
So the best of us could do it,
the lifting the body weight.
So I was just thinking,
this guy's doing this.
He is as strong as the teenagers
or 20s, up there, right?
So this is crazy.
So I thought, wow, that
should be my standard--
to create a program and
to create a standards
from these 80-year-olds
and transfer
the Olympic weightlifting to
find the exercise that people
could perform and would gain
the power and the strength
at that level and have
it throughout life.
And it was that idea.
Now, the routine,
of course, would
need to cover a lot of things.
So flexibility--
everything would
be but one that could make the
power, that could make people
stronger and live
life in a better way.
So that would be flexibility.
People need flexibility.
People need strength.
People need speed,
coordination, posture.
A certain ideal body
weight, so that food
would be needed to cover.
And then an exercise system that
would correct all the problems.
And the system had
to be reactive.
Reactive to the problems
that people already had.
Knee problems, hip problems, and
other problems with the body.
And microprogression had to
be implanted in the training
system.
So we did that.
But also there
was something else
that people had when
we trained them.
It was that people were
extremely stressed.
So the training, the exercise
routine, had to be mindful,
had to be pleasurable, joyful,
so people throughout their life
would come back to it.
And also it had to
be a singular focus.
So a singular focus had to be
implanted into the routine.
And that's what we did.
And it started being
magical as people
started really getting better.
And the program worked,
but still the program
needed some adjustment
on the mind side.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So it was really
the inspiration
from Charlie, seeing
what an 80-year-old
could do, that
led you to the work that
led into The Happy Body
and your system.
JERZY GREGOREK: Right.
So I will talk about
aging and would
like to show you
what really happens
and what I understood in 2002.
And so when we are
born until about 18,
everything is good for us.
We're getting better.
We are getting stronger.
And life really helps
us to really get better.
Whether we do anything or not,
we are actually getting better.
[LAUGHS]
So then it goes--
then something happens at
about 18 and 35, where athletes
compete against each other,
and it doesn't matter
whether they are 35 or 18.
Everyone can win and between.
So this is the flat area.
But this is the flat
area where, really,
people who have families,
business, and children
and so on, this is the
flourishing, the most beautiful
time and most powerful time.
But after that,
everything goes down.
And then no matter
what, the life actually
is doing the opposite.
Life is aging us.
And the aging stars
about 35, really.
So when you look at the
older records in swimming
and running and weightlifting,
they show that from 35,
no matter what athletes do,
they deteriorate about 2%.
So if you want to be the
same, you need to improve 2%.
If you want to improve 2%,
you have to improve 4%.
Because this happens to you.
But this is the road
of the World Champion.
Of course the
purpose would be now
to take a person from being weak
and having pains and improve.
And then when you can see
where the 80-year-old is--
there's a huge gap between
the 80-year-old and the one
that doesn't train at all.
So this shows us that
after five years,
the records are going down.
And this is the
situation when people
choose how they actually--
after 35, when they
are top athletes,
they can go really
down steep, or they
can go on and become
very youthful, even
though they are 100 years old.
So what can be done
for any regular person
is the improvement is there.
And there is a huge gap between
anybody who doesn't train
and the one that is powerful.
So there is a huge reserve
for everybody to improve.
So I want to show you
now something special.
So I coached this cerebral
palsy boy who came to me.
He was 25 years old.
When he came, he was lethargic.
He was completely
dependent on his parents.
He couldn't put his
clothes on himself.
And he couldn't focus
for a minute or longer.
Didn't have energy.
So I tested him the first
day, he couldn't press.
He couldn't take, off the
rack, 15 pounds aluminum bar.
He was so weak.
And that's after-- this is
one of these first days.
Let me show you this.
OK?
So he's pressing
this 15 pound bar.
He's very weak.
Right?
So after 2 and 1/2 years, the
boy presses his body weight.
154 pounds.
So 1,000% difference.
2 and 1/2 years of
work and 1,000%.
So his life completely
changes because of it.
He has now strength
enough to read books,
to go to school,
to clothe himself,
to go to toilet on his own.
All of it happens because of
the microprogression training
and constant
improvement of energy.
What else happens is
that his brain was
very simple at that time.
He didn't have any
conversation because he
didn't have in the
brain anything else
than actually going to
sleep or time to eat.
So after about a year, I asked
his father, so what changed?
And he said, well, we had a
first conversation, something
like that.
Or that the [INAUDIBLE]
was in the car,
and he saw a car on the side.
So I didn't know
what was it about.
But the father said that he
was always sleeping in the car,
and then one day,
he said, a car.
So he saw the car.
So his energy started
keeping him more awake.
So he saw the car.
He said, what was the car?
He didn't know what was the car.
So I said, the next day,
when you drive home,
notice what the car.
So he did.
It was a Toyota Prius
or a Volkswagen. I said,
who drove the car?
And then he said, I don't know.
So I said, OK.
Remember that.
It was a woman or a man.
And how old.
So he needed to see that.
Then it was on and on until he
saw the driving license and all
of these details.
So his brain was
really evolving.
So we'll show you what
happened after 2 and 1/2
years of training.
He has a special moment because
he presses his body weight.
This is a big deal for anybody.
It doesn't matter whether you
are cerebral palsy or not.
OK.
Right here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Great.
Good.
Great.
Still great.
- Go for it!
- 70 kilo!
Body weight!
- Yes!
[GRUNTS]
- All right!
JERZY GREGOREK: So he is-- you
are seeing his leg is up here,
and the expression of--
[END PLAYBACK]
So his leg is very tight.
His right side of the body
is weaker than the left.
So there are some adjustments.
But the power is growing and
overriding everything around,
making him more like normal.
So he is at the beginning.
He's jumping here on one inch.
When he came, he couldn't
detach himself off the floor.
He didn't have energy for that.
All right?
And here he's trying
to jump on one inch,
after probably about
two or three months.
And now he is jumping--
trying to jump here on--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Do it!
- Yeah.
- Yes!
JERZY GREGOREK: 11 inches.
So he tries.
And you can see how he
drags his right leg behind.
But he tries, and he tries.
He has a really great spirit.
He's like an athlete.
- Yeah!
Yes!
Yeah!
That's it.
JERZY GREGOREK: And you
see, when he does one time,
his brain repeats it.
Even five times.
It's amazing.
- [CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JERZY GREGOREK: You can see
his energy now is really high.
And he's powerful, and
he's able now to almost do
anything what we actually do.
So that gave me the
idea that actually it
doesn't matter where we start.
That what matters is that when
we find where we start and make
it better.
Because when I coach
athletes at all kind of ages,
sometimes a tennis player comes
in, and it's a 12-year-old.
And I ask, OK, let's jump
on box this height or this.
There's always a height when
anybody is scared to jump on.
So when you cannot jump
on 1 inch or 25 inch,
it really doesn't matter.
What matters is where you
start, and improve that.
And his improvement is
because he starts very low.
So he has this huge
gap for improvement.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
We were talking about that
before the talk this afternoon.
And it was really striking
because I called out--
I know people with cerebral
palsy-- and it was so dramatic,
the improvement there.
And that sort of punchline,
that to a degree,
we all have our starting
point, whether your set point
is 1 inch or 24 inches.
It's really about how do
you move from wherever
you're starting and improve.
And there may be more
headroom for an average person
like myself to where
a top athlete is
than even cerebral palsy
to what we call normal.
JERZY GREGOREK: Right.
Because he improved 1,000%, but
normal people have about 300%.
So I am 63 years old, but I'm
a World Champion at that age.
So any 63-year-old
that I will face
will be a lot weaker than I am.
They could be a
lot weaker, right?
So when people come to my
place, and they find out
that I am 63 years old, and
that I can do whatever I can do,
it's just mind blowing for them.
But at the same time,
it's very inspirational,
very motivational.
The people see it and say,
oh, I can be that way.
So now I want to show
you something else.
This is a 64-year-old man who
comes into our place and trains
for 11 years.
He's 75 now.
And he comes after
11 years and says,
you know, I was 64 when I
came here, and I was weak.
I was inflexible.
I had replaced two hips.
And it was just really--
my life was going down.
But after 11 years, I'm a lot
better off than when I was 64.
And actually, I can do
things that I couldn't
do when I was in my 20s.
So he performs full snatches
with two hips replaced.
He's 75.
So if he is like
that, there is a lot
of room, really,
what could be done.
When Tim first came to
me about three years ago,
he had some pains in his
body because he really
challenged himself
and found himself
to be sore in many
places and inflexible.
So it took me about
two years to help
him to become flexible
and do things like this.
And he was able to do
it after two years.
But Tim Ferriss is a
unique personality, too,
because he always
came with a journal,
and he wrote all the
notes and things.
So he didn't waste time.
And it was very
engaging every one
hour when he was in my place.
It was engaging.
He understood the
microprogression,
that we do microprogression.
And because of
microprogression, we
help people actually to
get better and better.
So then he knew that a lot
of people come to our place,
and they want to get better, and
they have difficult situations.
So he called us that
we mend broken people.
[LAUGHS] So that was
Tim Ferriss' quote.
So something about
the posture you
know, the posture is very
important, especially
for people like you--
computers, computers.
And I have a lot of
surgeons that come,
and they do surgery like this.
And they have a lot of pains
in the back and mostly thoracic
spine.
And so the program had to
face the whole situation.
So how do we really
break the posture?
How do we age the posture?
So the first thing
that happens to us
is that we break
the thoracic spine
by lowering the sternum down.
So this happens.
See?
That's simple.
When this happens, my
head goes down too,
and my side lowers down.
So in order to
correct that, when
it happens in the whole one year
time, the head also moves up.
You see?
And adjusts to that
so the person can see.
And it's mostly kind
of like that begins.
But then when it really
goes, goes, goes worse,
that the person
cannot see ahead.
So that's the next stage.
The next stage is
the knees forward.
So it then goes like that.
Right?
You can see that.
And then people are really
tight at that moment,
so they move more that way,
without moving the spine.
So once the knees
are really tired,
then the cane is the
other way or the pusher.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: It's like
you're aging before our eyes
here.
JERZY GREGOREK: Yeah, yeah.
And then-- there's the chair.
And you're sitting.
It's hard to stand up.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
Can you go back to yourself?
This is freaking me out.
JERZY GREGOREK: Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's better.
Cool.
JERZY GREGOREK: So
we said mindfulness
and singularity and
posture and everything
is incorporated
into one routine,
then you do 30 minutes a day.
And that's the whole routine.
And in that routine
of 18 exercises,
the main purpose of the
routine is one exercise.
To be good in one exercise--
it's like weightlifting.
If you do good in
snatch, you are
good in anything in your life.
Doesn't matter whether you do
skiing or skating or whatever.
You will be great everywhere.
Because that's the
power of that one lift.
So there are hundreds of
exercises that weightlifters
do, but they don't matter.
They are only supportive
exercises to make one happen,
to be really the great in one.
So we have that one.
We call it power tower.
So all these exercises
are a routine.
The routine is established
with three sequences,
but mostly one is the aim.
And then that's how it looks.
So this is important.
Here, for the posture
and flexibility,
there are three main parts
of the body, really, at stake
here--
flexibility of the
ankles, flexibility
of hamstrings and the spine.
So when you have flexibility
in those three places,
you should be able to
easily descend down
without moving forward.
So descending
should be this way.
See?
Like this.
And then up-- so
you're not doing this
or raising your heels.
So when you don't
have flexibility,
you will not be able to do that.
But when you actually
raise your arms up,
it's even more difficult,
because the thoracic spine
is at stake.
So that exercise
helps with the ankles,
helps with the hamstrings, the
hips, and then also the spine.
So eventually, you
become like that.
Right?
So that also gave us the
idea that this exercise
should be like clean and jerk.
Now, we transfer all the
numbers to that exercise,
and that exercise
became the standard
for strength and
standard for speed.
If you are good in that,
you are good to live life.
And if you're good at
that when you are 80, 90,
well, you are good
at that moment.
So we created this
system that you would,
when you are 30 and 40,
you can actually get better
at that time, and
easy for you it
would be to be as strong
as that 80-year-old
when you are 30 and 40 and 50.
And you keep that until
you are 90 or 100.
Fantastic life.
Incredible.
That 80-year-old,
Charlie Henderson,
we went on the banquet after
the World Championship,
and we met him there.
He came.
He entered the room like this
with his wife, you know, soft--
the spine, the hips, everything.
He's like a 15-year-old.
Like a ballet
dancer he's walking.
He's not like an 80-year-old.
His wife, 80-something too, and
then she walked the same way.
And they pick up the champagne,
and then they started talking.
Like, you know, wow,
just unbelievable.
So we really engaged
them into conversation.
Talked about nutrition.
Talked about exercise.
How you actually do this so
your joints and everything
stays really healthy
and not being injured.
And then we got a lot of
tips how microprogression
could work, and how
with age, you actually
adapt yourself to it.
Beautiful.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So I want
to encourage people to start
thinking about questions.
We have a mic over there.
We'll have about five
minutes for questions.
I just want to ask a
few more questions.
Being able to stick to this
and accessibility for anyone,
is microprogressions
the key that
makes this so addictive
and consistent?
How does it work that
not only athletes,
but normal people can--
or even people
with cerebral palsy
who can adhere to a
program like this?
JERZY GREGOREK: So when
we have certain weaknesses
that we want to
correct, and then we
have the plan and
strategies-- so The Happy Body
is that plan and strategy.
Something else comes up,
which is ability to apply.
And that ability to apply,
we dealt with in the last 10
years, after
publishing the book,
how to actually make it happen.
During this time, I
talked to my clients a lot
about Plato and horses and
our emotions and the mind.
How that plays.
And then he gave us
a really great image.
He said, imagine that
your chariot is your body,
and the horses are your
feelings, emotions.
And the mind is the rider.
He said that when the
horses are dragging
the rider against his
will, danger is coming.
So that's where
addictions happen
and all problems and so on.
So I thought about
this a long time.
And we focused for
about six, seven years
of controlling those horses.
But whenever you control the
horses, something else happens.
It's that we don't like it,
so we start being against it,
and we jump back.
And so how do you actually--
what do you do with the horses?
And I came out with the
idea that these horses
have to be befriended.
So you work with
poetry and stories
and then talk to people
around, and you change, slowly,
the brain patterns that those
horses are aligned with,
whatever the mind wants.
So at the beginning,
when something is hard,
when you want to do
something, and it's good,
you will not like it usually,
because it takes-- energy
takes practice, like you said.
But when you keep
doing at the beginning,
you are like a stoic.
You want to control something.
But if you want to control
something that is difficult,
it's hard.
Then you will be not liking it.
So you can achieve it, but
you will be more resistant,
and you will not be happy.
But when you switch,
actually, to the other side,
then you become this--
I call it a happy
stoic, the happy stoic.
The happy stoic is the one that
is aligned with what is good,
what needs to be improved,
and actually likes it.
So this is the example.
I notice over and
over that's what
happens with losing weight.
Somebody is 160 pounds and
loses weight, becomes 120.
But if the brain doesn't
shift, the person stays at 160.
The brain is in 160.
The body is in 120.
And if the brain is not
shifted, then the brain
will take back the body to 160.
That's the lifestyle.
And that is, here,
extremely important
work that takes the
person from a certain body
weight to the other
side and creates
this likability and changes
the whole living system,
that you become, the
person becomes 120,
and the brain becomes--
they start liking it.
And it takes time,
but once it happens,
the happy story becomes.
So for us, the recent theory
is that we like dance,
and we pick up this three
months, four months,
our next thing--
120 brain.
You have the metaphor for it.
So we go, and we learn dancing
and so on, and it takes heart,
but in some years,
we'll be dancers.
Yeah?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Awesome.
I want to make sure we have
time for a few questions,
so I'll repeat them if you
can't make your way to the mic.
So any questions for Jerzy?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So when you presented that
singular exercise, the flow,
and you demonstrated that, if a
person starts at a place where
you actually couldn't completely
do that exercise perfectly, do
they just keep--
is your strategy keep
doing that exercise,
and you will get
better, or should you
do something else complementary
to increase flexibility
before you do that exercise?
JERZY GREGOREK: So what we
do is make a progression.
So we set up the levels
of squatting to work.
So you find the
person when the person
is with dumbbells up
and squatting down.
So when it comes to the point
when the heel is going up,
or the body leans forward,
you measure that level
and sit toward that level.
And then when you
find that level,
then you train until that
level becomes comfortable.
And then you say, one inch
lower, one inch lower.
Two weeks, three weeks, four
weeks, five weeks, and you're
slowly, slowly going down
and down until you recover,
completely, flexibility for
that particular exercise,
like Power Tower.
AUDIENCE: So it is
the same exercises.
JERZY GREGOREK:
The same exercise.
AUDIENCE: You progress.
JERZY GREGOREK: Yes, within.
So you train it like
doing pole vaulting.
You are a pole vaulter, here.
You Power Tower, so you
work with one exercise.
So we can do with
you just short thing.
You can stand up
and test yourself,
whether you can go
down toward the chair.
Stand up, please.
And then you will see
if you can do that.
And put your arms on your
chest and try to sit back.
Sit back and see if you can sit
back without leaning forward.
So you can see that at a certain
moment you just lean forward.
And that is the moment that
you need to start working with.
You see it.
And mostly we just
squat that way
and not using our hamstrings
and hips and other joints.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So that question
was great, because
it really helped
me understand that one of
the bases of your system
is that anyone can do it.
It's a question of degree,
like you said before.
And you can do this
right and then continue
with microprogressions
to achieve more and more.
So from day one, you can
actually do the exercise.
I just did it, I
think, part of it.
And then it's a question
of applying yourself
and continuing to get
better and better.
JERZY GREGOREK: So
the whole system
is built to restore a person
from the level the person is.
So if you find
yourself-- there are
five levels for every exercise.
So if you find yourself
in one exercise level five
or another one level one, so
you work with those levels,
and when time passes,
you will become better.
It's a lot of data
too, because you
are creating the same
routine, and you're
doing the same routine.
And because of it,
you start really
learning about what you do.
And then the data
you collect, you
are learning also
about how to adapt
that training system in
case something happens.
So you learn how to
increase the weight.
You learn how to increase
the depth squatting,
or you increase the speed.
And you start really working
on becoming this self coach.
And after a while, because
you are doing over and over
the same routine,
you actually learn.
You have the opportunity to--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
It's a framework
Googlers would
like, because it's
an experimental framework
with one variable
that you can measure, and--
JERZY GREGOREK: Oh, the tech
generations and all the tech
people will love The Happy Body.
Because they love the science.
Everything is science
in The Happy Body,
whether it is flexibility,
whether it is strength,
whether it is ideal body
weight, whether it is leanness,
everything is in numbers.
It's mathematics all of it.
So because it's mathematics,
tech people and engineers
love it.
They say, oh, I love it.
Oh, yes.
And then they can
do it for months
and come back and then take
the tune up a little bit.
But mostly engineers, fantastic
when it comes to The Happy Body
measure and following.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We like
things we can measure.
We're almost out of time.
One more question from someone?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
ask you again about adherence
and that if you're a coach,
coaches love athletes,
because you just give them
a program, and they do it.
They want to get better.
They want to succeed.
They want to win.
And I think, often, with
non-athletes or normal people,
even if you have
a great program,
if you don't stick
to it, you're going
to get suboptimal results.
So have there been
any trends or things
you've noticed when
you work with someone
about their ability to stick
or not stick with the program?
Where might someone
relapse, or where might they
really succeed?
JERZY GREGOREK: This way,
in the last 10 years,
we created a lot of
help in that area.
I wrote three
books of dialogues.
And I noticed that
we have a dialogue
in our mind between
fatalist and the master.
And the dialogue
about the choices.
And one book is about
dialogues between fatalist
and the master when
it comes to food.
The one, exercise.
And the other one
is about the rest.
And then there
are 12 situations,
and there is dialogue between
the fatalist and the master.
You learn how to hear that
you have those two, first.
And then you learn how
strong is the fatalist,
and how strong is
the master, and learn
how to write down the
situations and write, actually--
and the dialogue with
the master of 51%.
So if you can do
that, over time,
you're actually getting better.
All right?
That's the three books of
dialogues that work with it.
The other book is "I Got This."
So it's training-- the grit--
reading stories, reading poems,
and especially written by us.
So you need to submerge yourself
with people that actually
do this, also read
stories or watch
videos and everything that can
help you to stay on the track,
right?
Because really,
we don't know what
words work to a certain
person at a certain time.
We noticed that after many
years of working with people
that certain words
work for one person
but don't work for another one.
For example, after four years,
that woman came, and she said--
and I asked her, so
how is it that you
are able to change this
already for four years
and then stick to it?
And she said, you
told me four words.
And I said, what four words?
Two years will pass, I told her.
But I didn't remember.
But these four words
stuck with her.
She had the imagination that
the two years will pass,
and then she will be, in two
years, somewhere in the place,
and engaged her and
inspired her to do
the program until the end.
So I want to close with in
other words, it is time.
So I met this ballet
dancer who was injured
and who lost weight.
And he gained back.
The brain, 160 and 120.
So he gained back the
weight after about 10 years.
I met with him in LA.
And I said, Barnes, you
have to lose weight.
Yeah, yeah.
I have to lose weight.
And then I said, it is time.
And Barnes says, yeah, yeah.
You know when I did.
I said, Barnes, it is time.
And Barnes, yes,
but I did it then.
I said, Barnes, it is time.
And Barnes looks at me.
It is time?
I said, yeah.
It is time.
And I said, yeah, it is time.
And Barnes said, I got it.
It is time.
So he goes home, and in
about four or five months,
loses 50 pounds.
So we know that somewhere,
the words and the story
is very motivational
and very powerful
to do what you need to do.
So let's say today.
You could think about what
you want to get better.
What is the one
thing that you want
to go home and start improving?
But if you want to really do
that, you have to pick up one.
Not two.
Just one.
If you want to be
flexible, pick up that one.
And then start working with it.
If you want to be strong,
you do the strong.
If you want to lose
weight, do that.
But just pick up one and
start really committing to it,
that you will do it every day.
And priority, you will
have priority for that one.
So every day, no matter
what, you will do this,
and you will do this.
And you start
improving over time.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: All right.
JERZY GREGOREK: So sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JERZY GREGOREK: Oh, yeah.
The hard choices
usually align with--
hard choices, easy life.
It's that what you want to
improve, it needs to happen.
It's like with the stoic.
It's hard to start to control.
Something, what will make
you better over time,
and usually we don't
like it at the beginning.
So we are the stoic
controlling something,
but we don't like it.
And our challenge here is
how to transfer the brain
toward that goodness that you
want to happen and like it.
For me it was two potatoes
versus one potato.
One potato-- I love potatoes.
I want more potatoes.
But one potato, I
know, The Happy Body
tells me one potato is
enough not to get fat.
OK?
But I like two potatoes.
My horse is two
potatoes, three potatoes.
Not one.
So after a while, I--
but I choose one potato
as a stoic, not two.
But I'm not happy, because
I want two potatoes.
So my big challenge here
is how to transform myself.
Transition myself
to the one potato
and hot to change my believing
system that I actually
like one potato.
And that is the happy stoic.
The happy stoic is that one.
So today, I will
choose one potato.
I don't want two potatoes.
I want one potato.
But it's the whole
experiences that
happen throughout the year or
two that build that transition.
But it is possible.
And it is really beautiful.
So when you pick up something,
it will be a hard choice.
And it will be hard
choice for a while.
But when you really stick it,
you go home and say, this is--
I'm going to do it.
And start working on it
like we work with the dance.
And even though it's
hard, even though you
have to wake up
and do it, or you
pay for it, like we pay for
the dances, it doesn't matter.
But one thing, not two.
One.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
On that note, that will
have to be the last word.
Thank you.
We really appreciate
your enthusiasm.
You're the living embodiment
of what you teach.
So thank you for that.
JERZY GREGOREK:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]